you think about like Planet Fitness
marketing from a business model
perspective it's brilliant they looked
at it and they were like okay 92% of
people don't actually want to use
anything in the gym they want to sign
out for a gym and not come okay the
people who use the gym the most who we
lose money on a per usage basis are
people who actually use the gym what do
people who use the gym you they use
heavy weights they use squat rat they
use chalk and so they're like well if we
eliminate these three things that knocks
out 80% of the people who actually going
to use the gym so then we can have a
facility sign up as many people as
possibly can knowing they're ever going
to come and then we'll incentivize them
with pizza it's 10 bucks a month to come
here if you just come and get pizza once
a month you already covered your 10
bucks the average Planet Fitness does
has 10,000 members so for them to make
their model work it's 10,000